what's the next category actually
catchphrase of the year
i have a feeling i i know what it's
going to be i know this one's i know
let's see the nominees let's see the
nominees
i [ __ ] with this i'm proud of that one
uh x with attitude
again this is attributed to my dad not
me uh i worked at the bbc
classic is that a clown is is that a
catchphrase yeah or just or just a thing
that
and i say the the diamond in the rough
right here why are you laughing me lean
i love that we have friends that
literally like like techtone goes to
ghana's like god do you look at the bbc
yeah everyone jokes to god about working
at the bbc
he says it's so [ __ ] much off camera
this is like the probably the biggest
in-joke within our like friend 100
uh in terms of the iconic catchphrase i
think this completely goes down to like
how much it was memed and how often we
actually say it right
and i feel i mean it's it's different it
hits differently
i mean i know we say that a lot we
didn't invent them yeah we didn't invent
it
i would say the one that we say the most
that we invented was x with attitude
right yeah yeah i mean i've i've like
i've
i think i've been hanging out with joey
too much because i've started to say i
[ __ ] with this more often
i like it i'm like you know you know you
know that phrase that you start off
saying ironically because you wanna like
you wanna like yeah you wanna joke
around and then it turns into like oh
i'm just saying this all the time now
that's me with i [ __ ] with this what can
i say i'm a trendsetter
on that one oh my god i i mean
honestly i probably think it's going to
be it hits different i mean it hits
different but it's going to be
bittersweet
i think you will win actually really
really i think there could be something
else i could do
i'm i'm hoping like the black horse
right here is the why you're laughing
i really like my favorite yeah i really
hope this wins
yeah so uh let's find out i guess you
have the uh
that's fine let us know who wins find
out this will forever solidify okay the
catchphrase of the year
is it hits different and here's
different
i mean it do hit different though i feel
like it's so generic and not
we didn't make it yeah right we didn't
make it that that one it's bittersweet
it's bittersweet but
we appreciate you guys for all that does
that mean we have to come up with a new
catchphrase for next year yeah yeah
every year we need a new catchphrase
yeah we need a new catchphrase what was
the percentages
uh it hit a different one with 49.7
[ __ ] hours
yeah not second place in second place
with 21.4 percent of the vote is
why are you laughing yeah
there we go okay
it got so close oh man
was after that third place was uh i
worked at the bbc
i got i've got to find somewhere else to
work so i can do libraries so we can
start a new catchphrase i apologize
the third place was axel's attitude oh
okay
that makes more sense that makes more
sense because yeah
i mean i i'd say that makes sense i'm a
bit disappointed but it makes sense yeah